voulait tenir tête à Pékin il a plutôt
goûté à la médecine de l'ingérence
chinoise
victime dit le député conservateur d'une
campagne de dénigrement orchestrée par
le régime communiste des messages
mensongers sur wechat l'équivalent
chinois de Twitter dirigé contre lui et
le Parti conservateur accusé notamment
de vouloir limiter les activités
politiques chinoises en sols canadien
les faits sur le terrain a été immédiat
une famille chinoise amicale avait
installé mon affiche électorale donnant
leur maison en 2019 dit-il
après la campagne de désinformation
cette même famille m'a claqué la porte
tournée m'a accusé d'être un traître
selon un rapport top secret du SCRS le
régime chinois aurait tenté d'influencer
les résultats dans une dizaine de
circonscriptions
confrontés à ces informations juste un
Trudeau répète le même message depuis
plusieurs semaines l'intégrité de nos
élections n'ont pas été compromises
l'opposition conservatrice elle accuse
le Premier ministre de jouer à
l'autruche pourquoi parce qu'il a
bénéficié donc il n'a aucun problème à
permettre un gouvernement
autoritaire étrangers se mêler dans nos
affaires c'est difficile pour moi
d'envisager quelque chose de plus
important que l'intégrité de notre
système électoral cette ex directeur des
services de renseignement croient qu'une
enquête publique comme la commission
rouleau permettrait de faire la lumière
sur l'ingérence étrangère loin de la
partisanerie politique je pense qu'avoir
une commission d'enquête avec un pouvoir
de convoquer des gens et de d'insister
sur l'accès à des documents privé
permettrait des commissaires de
réassurer rassurer le public une
suggestion appuyée par le NPD et le Bloc
québécois et on est le seul parti des
trois parties qui veut une enquête
nationale publique c'est égal là ni les
librairies ni les conservateurs semblent
vouloir à embarquer une enquête
indépendante publique permettra de faire
la lumière et s'assurer dans le futur
qui est pas qui est pas quoi que ce soit
qui se met dans le chemin de l'électeur
et de son droit de vote le rapport sur
l'intégrité de l'élection de 2021 sera
finalement rendu public par le
gouvernement 17 mois après le scrutin ce
n'est pas une coïncidence selon les
parties d'opposition qui trouvent que le
moment est choisi pour favoriser les
libéraux afin d'aider à faire baisser la
pression
ici Christian Noël Radio-Canada Ottawa